nous allons nous connecter les filles du
coin wifi ça veut dire allonger sommes
en l'y attend mois
cette vache en route vers la date soit
le même pour toi dans le décor regarde
là haut et jean même une tournure sur la
soif on saura au blue route et perdez
votre graisse abdominale grâce à cette
astuce et joyeuse ménagères veulent vous
rencontrer
ah bon tu est enrichie en jouant à des
jeux vidéos qu'elle concerne assez
méchamment dangereuse tiens tiens tiens
je sauve ma peau
on sait jamais qui on peut rencontrer
[Musique]
y'a que des gens bizarres ici
j'espère l'internet s'effondre
je suis vert de peur
[Musique]
quoi tu savais toi qu'il y avait autant
de bébés de chats dans le monde c'est
pour ça que permettent a été inventé
[Musique]